in this video we are going to look into
how to prepare a 3D model for this Stone
and furthermore I would like to make it
into a ring with the 3D printing and
casting and set the stone for the whole
process are you ready let's get
[Music]
started first let's find out the size
for the stone I want to measure the
width length and the height it is coming
into 13.2 29 by
1833 and
7.79 with the digital caliper let's go
to the top view and we are going to use
the oval command and Friendly Center
we're going to hit zero to center it the
first number we're going to put it in
there is
1329 ided by 2 since we only use half of
it the second number we're going to put
it here is 18.33%
by two and then so that give us the base
for our
curve let's go into the front view we're
going to use the line Command right here
and going up for
7.79 all right so that is how high it is
going to be to creating this surface I'm
going to use the curve tool coming at
the front view I will like to snaping
into the end
point and
quadron starting from the end point and
coming down roughly about here we want
to make sure that SM track is on and
we're going to come into the top and
snapping into the quadrant so this is
the curve that we have over here you can
also use the other way to get a smoother
line by putting a little tab here and
also another tab here so instead of draw
the line I will use the blend tool to
blend from this point to this
point so that way you will get really
smooth line over there the command we're
going to use next to creating the stone
it's called rail revolve we're going to
pick up the the curve and then we're
going to pick up the rail and and tell
it the Rhino where is the AIS and that's
how we get this one using the cap
command we'll make this surface into the
solid and then this is will be our Stone
it may not exactly the same with your
stone on the profile but it's for the
rendering purpose the key component is
the curve that we have on the bottom
coming to the front view let's make a
ring shank size
I'm going to make it diameter 16 mm and
move my stone
up roughly about here for the high
definitely you need to consider the
thickness on the bottom for the better
casting now we have everything in the
position I do want to have this curve
offset a little bit bigger it's really
depends on the shrinkage of your wax and
your casting if you know that it's a
certain shrinkage you might want to go
by the shrinkage for the demonstration
purpose I'm just going to go 2 mm
slightly bigger for the stone so that
way when my model shrink a little bit it
will fit let me offset this guy and this
is this time the offset will be the
thickness so I'm going to make it 1 mm
and that will be the thickness of my
metal over here and I'm going to rebuild
this curve currently it has 50 point is
because it's coming from offset I'm
going to change it to 12 of
them so I have the curve look like this
let's make a copy
first and pick up one of it we want to
pick up those control Point like every
other control
point so holding your shift and click
and that's moving the gumball up so we
have the basic shape over there let's go
ahead to create the other shape we are
going to use this Command right here for
the
ellipsoid and we are going to use the
diameter that's clicking on the first
Quant second quadrant and the third one
and for the high I wanted to go over a
little bit and so that will giveing a
nice taper looking to actually to cut
this we are not able to trim it unless
this curve is attached to the surface so
we're going to use the command called
pull we're going to pull this curve back
to this surface now you see the curve is
hopping on this surface with that curve
is Select let's go ahead to trim the top
off that's how we get our first shell
there due to the shrinkage I would like
to this surface follow that point2
guideline that I have there so let's go
ahead to offset this surface let's pick
up this surface and we want to offset
for 2
mm we don't want it to be solid just
that surface right there and we are
going to pull it back one more time this
time pull this curve back to this
surface
okay and you may notice that you have
something like this is because we we
have a seam over there it's really
simple to solve we just need to pull one
more time because every time you pull
you can only pull into a single surface
so we are going to pull and we're going
to pull from that to this surface so now
we have those two curve let's go ahead
to join them and use them to trim off
the surface over
there okay that's using the surface from
planer curve and let's pick up this
curve and creating this surface right
there let's join this one and this one
together second things we need to do is
we want to creating the surface over
there that's using the blend surface
tool and make sure that the chain age is
yes so we want to pick up this ages and
pick up this edes you can adjust the
bump if you like to and once we have
everything we just need to go ahead to
join everything double check that if
this is a solid right here on my
property showing close solid poly
surface now we have done that we need to
creating the ring shap I'm going to use
the uh Cony Corners rectangle tool and
snapping in the
center to the quadon and let's take a
look on the Right View and let's move it
it down so you get something look like
Square the oval that's using the move
tool to move from the quadrant to the
quadrant so it's not cutting inside of
the ring shank second things I wanted to
do is to mirror that to the top I'm
going to use the 3D scale from here to
here and moving up a little bit like
whatever size that is suitable we're
going to the surface with the sweep one
rail this is going to be the rail
crosssection and
crosssection make sure they are align
and I personally like them to be aligned
in
the inside of the ring shank so that's
moving to inside of the ring shank and
make sure all the arrow is aligned to
the same
direction it's going to do only half of
them is because we need to close the
sweep on the option here so that's how
we get this one we're going to have a
bowling split this one out of the shell
that we pick and let's Del it everything
inside now let's go ahead to bowling
unit together double check that it is
still closed solid polish
surface once we have done that I do like
it to look very nice and wrong on
everywhere so I'm going to giveing a
little bit fet so let's go to the fet
edges command and let's do try one and
see how this go all right look really
nice and we're going to try that again
all right so now I have this nice and
round we need to cut off anything is
shouldn't be inside of a ring shank go
to the solid extrude a planer curve
straight and let's use the bowling
difference this out of this
one sometimes your difference will fit
it's because all the seam is currently
perfectly aligned right now so what I
like to do is actually I want to make
them just slightly bigger roughly about
that it's really hard to tell by the eye
but it does make the bowling job much
easier let's go into bowling difference
this one will be out of this
one all right so now we have everything
ready this is
double let double check this is still
Clos polish surface and we are ready to
3D print and cast this one don't forget
to check the video on the Thursday I'll
show you my printing result casting
result and how I set this stor see you
next
[Music]